Everyone knows that
ice is colder than water,
but usually, you're not
going to freeze water
just by adding some ice cubes.
Today, we're going to see
if we can supercool our ice
to the point where
it'll actually freeze water solid.
[Music]
Today, we're doing a fun experiment
using liquid nitrogen, ice, and water.
Three different levels
of temperature here,
and we're going to see
if we can take some regular cubed ice,
put it in liquid nitrogen
until it's absurdly cold,
and then drop it into water.
We're trying to see if we can
make the water hit sort of flashpoint,
but in reverse.
Where it will just suddenly freeze,
because we've dropped
the temperature so much.
Normally, if you
put ice into water,
you're just going to get cold water.
We want to see if we can
make the ice so much colder than water
that the water
will actually freeze
in the process of
trying to warm the ice up.
Here's the basic idea.
We've got some liquid nitrogen.
We've got a bunch of
ice cubes and some water.
We're going to dip
the ice into liquid nitrogen,
cooling it down way more
than a normal freezer would,
and then we'll see
if that supercooled ice
can steal enough heat
out of water for it to freeze.
We have a number of stemware cups,
and we're using this type
because I think it might have
less glass in contact with
the water heating it back up.
A lot of the time,
a glass cup will have
a sort of thick bottom to it,
and that seems like
it would just hold enough heat
that it would just keep
our water from freezing.
So I'm hoping that the stemware
will have a little bit less of that.
We'll see if it works.
To start off as sort of control test,
we're going to pour
some water into a cup,
measure the temperature,
and then add a bunch of ice,
and see what temperature
drops it down to.
Guys, quick announcement.
We have got some shirts
that are going on sale
in our store now.
That's right, guys.
So the next two weeks,
the "I Tried it at Home"
and the "Look Mom, No Hands" shirts
are only $19.99.
They're really soft,
so if you want one,
click the link
in the description below.
Nice.
This water is chilled.
I've had it in the fridge for a while,
but I don't think
it's anywhere near freezing.
It's a 9.2 - 8.9 degrees Celsius.
Let's add some ice into our cup.
See what change we get.
[Music]
Getting some nice condensation
on the outside of the glass,
always a good sign that things
are cooling down.
[Music]
It's only been a minute or so,
but let's see what temperature
were clocking in at.
[Music]
We're already several degrees cooler
than where we were before.
37 degrees Fahrenheit.
Dropping still a little bit.
Let's give that another minute of
stirring and see where we get.
[Music]
All right.
Down to 34 Fahrenheit or 1.1 Celsius,
so that's pretty cold.
That's getting very close to the temperature
of the phase shift between
liquid and solid water.
[Music]
Mmm, chilly.
Yeah, that was fairly cold,
at least in terms of food we eat,
and temperatures we
regularly experience.
But over here,
we've got liquid nitrogen,
which of course is
a whole different beast,
and doesn't really even register
to us on just how cold it is.
For instance, I'm not going to put the
thermometer in the liquid nitrogen.
That's far too cold.
I'm just going to put it in the vapors
between the surface of the liquid
and the top of the container.
And we're below
zero Fahrenheit by a lot,
and we're approaching
some of the coldest
temperatures ever experienced
by anyone on Earth,
and at that point,
we have gotten so cold
that our thermometer
can no longer handle it.
Somewhere around 60 degrees below zero fahrenheit.
It's too cold, and like I said,
this is not in the liquid nitrogen.
Liquid nitrogen is still
down there below a little bit.
So now, we're going to take some ice,
and we're going to super cool
it in our liquid nitrogen,
and then see what happens
when we introduce it to our water.
All right, we've stopped bubbling,
which means we probably have
our ice cube down to this temperature,
or very close to the temperature
of the liquid nitrogen itself.
Just gonna set this on the counter,
try and put our temperature
probe in contact with it.
Zero Fahrenheit.
That's a negative 18 Celsius.
There were at a, we're about
50 degrees below Fahrenheit,
and about 45 degrees below Celsius.
I think it's actually far colder than that.
But because the probe
is just resting on it,
it's still getting exposure
to the air around us.
It's not going to drop all the way
down to the temperature of the ice.
But now, let's see what happens
if we take some water
and several supercooled ice cubes,
and see what we can do to
the temperature of the water.
That's about where our water is,
48 degrees Fahrenheit.
Layer of ice just forms
around the tongs so fast
because they're almost
as cold as liquid nitrogen itself.
[Music]
Our single supercooled ice cube
has only reduced the temperature
of our cup of water by about 3 degrees.
But let's try adding several of them.
We had a handful before
when you tried normal ice.
I'm curious to see if we can get
a handful of supercooled ice cubes.
[Music]
Liquid nitrogen is just boiling away.
Our ice is so hot, it's causing
our liquid nitrogen to boil.
Looks like we have frozen our ice cubes.
Water is starting off at about
45 and 1/2 Fahrenheit.
[Music]
Our super cold ice cubes,
they hit the water,
and the water just forms
a frozen barrier around them,
almost immediately,
and that happened enough that all of
our ice cubes have now stuck together.
Got the temperature down
to 35 and 1/2 degrees Fahrenheit.
I think what we're seeing now...
I was hoping that we could
sort of cool the water down
to where it was almost at a point
when just another little bit of cold
supercooled ice would drop in,
and that would sort of
cause the whole cup to freeze.
Mostly, what we're having happen
is as I drop a piece of supercooled ice in,
it forms a layer of ice around itself.
So just the water that's directly in contact
with it loses in a heat turn into ice.
And then it doesn't spread
to the rest of the cup,
it kind of just slowly grows.
Like as this chunk of ice
has been sitting in the cup,
it's just been getting like a
thicker and thicker layer forming over it
that has just begun to
form a layer around itself.
It's kind of like a pearl forming in an oyster.
It just builds up
more and more around it.
Going to leave this in here
and keep stirring it,
and hope that it keeps
stealing heat away from the water,
cooling it down even more.
But I've also got some new
ice cubes in the liquid nitrogen,
and I'm going to take this
sort of blob cube out,
and put those new ones in,
and see if we can sort of keep going,
because it is lowering
the temperature in the cup,
but I'm kind of wondering
if we keep doing this several times,
if we keep adding
more even colder ice,
will we get to a point where the
whole cup is just like too cold,
and just all solidifies?
To really push this to a limit,
we've taken our cup,
filled it up with our supercooled ice,
and then poured some cold water on top.
And even with that,
while we have a lot of ice
forming around our cubes,
I don't think we've managed
to freeze the whole cup.
We had an experiment to see if we
could get a cup of water to flash freeze,
and when we put our supercooled
ice cubes into the water,
it just starts forming
an ice barrier around the cube,
and it really doesn't do a good job of
cooling down all of the water together.
I've sort of moved to seeing if
I can do a different experiment,
because I was so fascinated
by how those layers of ice formed.
I'm gonna see if
I can take our cube of ice,
and make sort of
a rainbow shell around it.
I've got six different colors of water,
and I'm going to try doing each color,
and then like a gap layer of regular ice,
and see how well this is going to work.
Here it goes.
[Music]
All right, here is my magic egg of ice.
I don't know how to break
through this nice and cleanly,
so I'm just going to kind of cut down,
and hope I get something of a clean edge.
[Music]
A little bit of a clean edge, not great.
Freezing so much, it has
sort of shattered into pieces,
but that is really cool rainbow
look right there.
That's seriously looks like
the inside of a jawbreaker.
All right, this turned out really cool,
and you can see really clearly
how thick each layer was.
Like you can count how many
times I dipped it in each color,
where I just dipped into
the water to sort of separate it.
But overall, this is really neat, and...
So unfortunately, we couldn't get
whole cups of ice to freeze solid.
But this ice layering thing
worked out really nicely,
and it took a ton of food coloring
to get it to really pick up the color.
But rainbow ice looks gorgeous.
I'll try and get it like dip it in water.
[Music]
Layered ice experiment worked
even better than I hoped it would.
This turned into quite
the jawbreaker looking piece.
It's fascinating.
Like you can just clearly see all the layers.
I think we got some good shots
where you can see the differentiation.
Even now, you can see a little bit as
it separates from one into the next.
Some people can taste food coloring.
I'm not sure if I'm one of those people.
[Music]
It just tastes like ice to me.
So, whether or not you can get
water to reach sort of a flash point
by putting supercooled
ice cubes into it, I'm not sure.
Maybe you can, but none of our
experiments got that to work.
We tried pouring really cold water
over our supercool dice.
We tried putting supercooled
ice cubes into the water over and over,
and we just never got the
water to cool down more,
and I'm pretty sure it's because
any water that comes in contact
with the supercooled ice
just starts forming a layer of ice around it.
We've done experiments
on the channel before
where we showed you
how you can put a water bottle
in the freezer for a
certain amount of time,
and then just by hitting the
bottle or tipping it out,
you can get all of it to
freeze at once.
But that's not what we're going for here,
and I'm sure if we had one of those,
and dropped a supercooled
ice cube in it, it would freeze.
But at that point, anything makes it freeze.
We're seeing if we could use
our supercooled ice
to get the water down
to that temperature,
and that wasn't very successful.
But I'm going to focus on the fact
that it was really successful
making our little rainbow
ice cube ball things here,
and they were there a lot of fun.
You got great variance of color.
Guys, that's all for today,
but the fun does
not end here.
That box at the top will take you
directly to our most recent video.
You should go check that out.
The other box will show you what YouTube
thinks you should be watching next.
If you are not a subscriber,
hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way, you'll never
miss out on a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you in the next one.
Talk to you then.